excuse moi guillaume je suis très choqué
par ta génération des hors la loi toi tu
respecte pas la loi quand je veux dire
merci martine chemise comme tout cas on
a du mékong calavi toi tu la respectes
moi tu la respectes pas d'accord il ya
aussi des gens qui ont du recul par
rapport à l'alouette japon 1 0 c'est
ridicule et absurde mais c'est important
dans une église c'est pas absurde parce
que c'est un lieu clos d'accord d'accord
mais excuse moi il faut pas vénérer
d'être hors la loi tu dois respecter la
loi et j'espère que tu respecte la loi
parce que sinon ça me fait beaucoup ça
me fait peur d'être à côté de toi oui
bah oui c'est ça mon nom c'est katia
mariens on est traités comme des
pestiférés m'a dit
tu mets pas de maj me recule à tel que
vides c'est dégueulasse je me recule ce
soir et on atteint les gens qui y monde
accorde un recul mais si t'as tendu avec
une semaine je ne recule pas ouais parce
que maman je suis négatif et ya des
règles
non mais je les bats disent le contraire
je pense qu'il faut respecter la loi je
pense que tu dis qu'il faut pas respecté
la loi je pense qu'il faut respecter ce
coup-là loin sans cesse que la loi
d'aujourd'hui était la loi il ya deux
ans non et non la loi un sens non elle
n'a aucun sens mais d'ascq ont emporté
pas à l'extérieur il ya six mois mais un
saut dans quatre mois tu vas voter il va
y avoir un changement de gouvernement
puisque tout le monde est contre ce
gouvernement il perçait marmande or les
sondages c'est pas que la réforme et non
mais comme tout le monde en a l'air de
dire ici sur ce plateau ce que ces mêmes
des cours dans les sondages on voit que
le président obama la plus dangereuse
d'abandon financiers comme ça la loi va
changer tu pourras ne plus mettre de
match tu pourras ne plus près de
présenter tout ce que tu veux mais tu es
mon maître de ce lien
nous pour l'odeur mais ces tournois vous
contentez de la situation actuelle vous
trouvé ça super de mettre des masses
vous trouvé ça super de missionnaires à
distance et non juste
horrible mais ne pas m'être ne pas
mettre un masque dans un dans des lieux
clos aujourd'hui j'estime que zemma bien
moi je pense que c'est un geste fort
alors que c'est dans cet hôpital qui va
permettre de masquer ouais super singe
est ev soit pas un hôpital c'est un
enterrement et des miettes pour la
roumélie détour sur la photo il était à
l'intérieur dans l'église et il y avait
beaucoup de personnes y avait plus de
150 aller en prison non j'ai pas dit
qu'il fallait qu'il aille en manuel von
ribbeck law la smacl alors vu justement
c'est un vrai geste de provocation des
priorités glace parce que il va quand
même et l'enterrement de deux personnes
qui sont mortes ducobu vide et il ne
m'est pas de masque il met en danger
tous les gens qui sont autour de lui je
trouve ça scandaleux en plus chez lg
pourtant j'ai beaucoup aimé francis
lalanne mais là il décolle vraiment il
ya en plus il a quand même fait des
déclarations en disant que même s'ils
avaient été vaccinés n'aurait pas été
plus protégés je suis désolé se sert de
la mémoire de ces de ses frères bogdanov
qui n'avaient pas fait état de leur non
vaccination si ça m'était des antilles
vax convaincu et qu'ils avaient essayé
de faire de faire du prosélytisme ok ils
pouvaient s'inscrire dans ça mais là je
suis désolé il se sert de la mort de ces
gens qui ont été discrets qui ont fait
un choix personnel et pour en faire une
polémique et se défont à nouveau sms et
d'isabelle morini-bosc elle est vraiment
très très bonne cette croyance
est vraiment très très bonne cette
[ __ ] at elle va finir par prendre ma
place d alexandra
oui tout d'accord avec sur une grande
partie de son intervention parce que
autant le fait ne pas porter le masque
on peut discuter il a sans doute tort
mais sur les déclarations excusez moi il
est dans le vrai de bout en bout il
connaissait les bogdanoff il connaît
leur choix il sait ce qu'ils ont fait il
assume je trouve ça très bien là c'est
pas du militantisme c'est de la vérité
ce qu'il dit et je trouve que les bruits
le dire à ce moment là voilà guillaume
toi le premier qui est un peu contre le
principe des vaccins et de et de te dire
que quand tu es vacciner tu peux
continuer à transmettre donc on est bien
d'accord que justement le masque ça peut
servir et ça fait barrière même s'il ya
plein de vacciner dans une salle mais au
moins si talmas non mais je pense que
lui sain au delà du fait de ma portée de
masse c'est un geste fort il veut
envoyer un message les jurés des
coureurs serpa de la disparition des
bonheurs c'est pas vrai c'est les gens
qui ont fait de la récupération là
dessus vous ne vous souvenez pas
quelques heures après leur décès y avait
déjà des gens qui est en train de leur
faire la morale donc oui il a répondu à
ça il a dit voilà moi j'ai fait le choix
comme eux de ne pas être vaccinés moi je
suis en bonne santé je pense moi aussi
envers les autres en fait des gens n'a
en c1 qui sont emmerdés
car ils sont traités comme des moins que
rien qu'on empêche de lire toute la
journée donc c'est bien que des gens
aussi garni sorte la voix de saison bien
se sente mise à l'écart voilà c'est une
personnalité publique et la droit de le
faire